Speaker 1: OK, from the standpoint of jobs
and unemployment, things are continuing to
improve.
And I am further reassured that what I told
you yesterday would happen by September, October,
November is going to.
And all of these right wingers, as I told
you yesterday, are very, very worried about
how it's more profitable to be on unemployment
than to go back and work jobs at restaurants
and retail stores and other places that are
now reopening as we exit the pandemic.
My position on this has been the enhanced
unemployment has been one of the most effective
pieces of covid stimulus.
Sure.
Anecdotally, there are some people who are
making roughly the same or maybe even a little
bit more with that enhanced unemployment.
And maybe they're choosing not to go back
to work for the time being, but that unemployment
is going to end and they're going to have
no choice but to go back to work.
We are starting to see this increasingly happen.
And we now have a new report from Yahoo!
Finance based on new Department of Labor data,
initial filings last week.
We just we learned today on Thursday, we get
the numbers.
For the previous week, new jobless claims
have dropped below 400000 for the first time
since March of twenty twenty.
This is a fifth consecutive week with a new
low.
This is now a 14 month low.
Fewer and fewer Americans are becoming newly
unemployed.
Initial jobless claims came in at three hundred
and eighty five thousand just below the expected
three hundred and eighty seven thousand.
Continuing claims are at three point seventy
seven million, slightly higher than the three
point six million that were expected.
Again, this is the first time since the start
of the pandemic where new jobless claims have
dropped below 400000.
And this is now starting to get close to the
pre pandemic weekly rate.
This is an important thing to understand.
This is not a political statement.
This is just what it is in a good, normal
economy.
You still have new unemployment claims every
week.
And, you know, we've talked before about at
what point does the risk of going out in the
world get back to the baseline level because
it was never zero even before covid you could
go out and catch the flu, you could catch
a stomach bug, you could get run over by a
bus, et cetera.
So it's about going back to the baseline we
were seeing even in the great economy that
I agree was was in place during the Trump
administration before the pandemic hit.
Great in many ways.
And yet we still had stagnant wages and other
issues.
You still saw 200 something new, 200 something
thousand new unemployment claims every week.
So when you look at that number three eighty
five, it's almost back down to the pre pandemic
level.
This is further evidence that as people's
unemployment benefits continue to start to
and continue to run out and as more and more
aspects of the economy are reopened, as more
and more people's kids go back to school so
that parents who don't have child care can
actually get back to work, we are going to
see the issue that the right claims is a big
issue of people just hanging out at home,
raking in the dough on unemployment.
It's going to resolve itself.
The unemployment is going to end.
The enhanced unemployment ends in September.
People state unemployment will ultimately
run out even with the various extensions that
different states provide.
And people are going to have to go back to
work.
Now, there's going to be a real question here
about whether we see stronger lobbying efforts
for better wages.
And, you know, the economy is a complicated
thing when we say, what about a 15 dollar
minimum wage?
As I said before, there are parts of the country
where cost of living is so high that a 15
dollar minimum wage is too low.
That's just the reality.
There are other parts of the country where
the cost of living is very, very low.
And going to a 15 dollar minimum wage immediately
actually could be a significant shock to the
economy, particularly states that still have
the federal minimum wage as the prevailing
minimum wage.
And so these are really regionalized issues,
much the same way depending on which state
you live in and depending on what the cost
of living is and depending on what the wages
are that are being paid there, there are jobs
that, as a result of all of this, are probably
going to have to start paying people more
in order to get people to come back to work.
Part of that is going to be because of some
large businesses, everything from, you know,
Amazon.
Bank of America has made an announcement,
a similar announcement have upped the minimum
wage that they are going to pay.
This is going to lead to some businesses having
to pay more in order to attract people.
And that's OK.
Now, if you said they're going to have to
pay one hundred bucks an hour, that's a straw
man.
Red herring.
That's not an equilibrium minimum wage.
It's not adjusted to cost of living.
It's not adjusted to anything that makes sense.
It's a straw man from the right.
They love to say, hey, listen, people having
more money is better.
Make the minimum wage 100 bucks an hour, make
it a thousand bucks an hour.
Nobody's calling for that.
That's a serious person because that's not
an equilibrium wage tied to inflation, productivity,
cost of living or any.
Else that being said, remember that when people
make more money, that is a cost to the employer,
but then people in the community have more
money to go and spend at that business and
imagine a hardware store, for example.
This is often an example that's given hardware
store all of a sudden has a higher wage.
They have to pay either because of the minimum
wage has gone up or because they need to raise
wages to attract workers.
They go from eight bucks an hour to 12 bucks
an hour.
Oh, their payroll costs have just gone up.
That's terrible, right?
That'll kill their business.
Well, hold on a second.
If the entire region now sees a twelve dollar
minimum wage instead of eight, you now have
all sorts of people who, because they are
earning more money, they're going to go to
the hardware store and say, hey, you know
what?
I'm going to get a new vacuum or I'm going
to get what I need to refinish my floors or
I'm going to finish my basement or whatever
the case may be.
And even though the hardware store now has
to pay more out in wages, they have all of
these customers that now have money to go
and spend and do projects.
So revenue goes up as well.
This analysis only works within what we would
consider an equilibrium wage.
It's really important to understand that.
So that's the latest in terms of unemployment
claims.
This is going to be resolved mostly on its
own.
Some businesses are going to have to start
paying more.
There's no question about that because they
have been paying submarket wages for a really
long time and that is going to be a problem
for them.
For the most part, this issue is going to
resolve itself.
I'm already seeing it happen in these numbers.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We've got a really great show for you today.
Lest we forget, I do want to mention that
our program is an independent non corporate
media program, we don't have big corporate
funders dumping money on us or a money tree.
I have many things in my backyard garden,
but no money tree at least that I've been
able to figure out yet.
We depend primarily on memberships from folks
like you who just go to join Pakman Dotcom
and sign up.
It's quick, it's easy, and until the end of
the week you can use the coupon code Memorial
twenty one.
This was the big Memorial Day special still
available through the end of the week.
Memorial twenty one gets you a beautiful discount,
only 19 bucks for an entire one year membership.
Can you believe my lawyers and accountants
are saying don't do it, David.
The staff is coming to me saying, sir, I don't
really make them call me sir.
Will we be able to earn our salary if the
memberships are so cheap?
Everybody relax.
It's a beautiful discount, 19 bucks for the
year if you use the code memorial.
Twenty one at join Pakman Dotcom.